durante 56 años la dualidad ha definido
a kamala harris nació en oakland pero
sus padres son inmigrantes de jamaica e
india- la educaron hindú pero eligió sal
protestante creció entre manifestaciones
pero rehusó ser activista como su madre
se hizo abogada y luego fiscal para
cambiar el sistema desde adentro así lo
dijo en junio al 'new york times'
consciente de su apuesta en el hinduismo
kamala significa fortuna y de 2004 2011
dirigió esta hacia su cargo de fiscal de
distrito en san francisco donde creó un
programa de reinserción de presos cree
que enfrentar las desigualdades
judiciales y a la vez ser firme contra
el crimen es posible y con esa certeza
de 2011 a 2016 ascendió a fiscal general
de california pero de nuevo lo dual la
contradicción marcaron su legado
judicial se opuso a la pena de muerte
para un hombre que mató a un policía
pero defendió la pena capital en el
sistema penal de su estado quiso poner
cámaras en los uniformes pero poco
proceso a policías en la muerte de
civiles ha defendido la justicia racial
pero como fiscal incrementó los
encarcelamientos
en 2017 se convirtió en senadora por
california en la cámara alta completó su
fama siendo una dura interrogadora
su siguiente objetivo fue la presidencia
su campaña decayó en 2019 no sin antes
dejar un combativo debate en las
primarias ante un joe biden que se jactó
de haber trabajado con senadores
segregacionistas
james jones
el estrés aún debe asentar su lugar
entre los más conservadores y la
fracción izquierda de los demócratas
también unirse denominado progresismo
con su pragmática carrera por la ley
pero fue ese espíritu crítico además de
su mezcla cultural lo que hizo que byd
en la incluyera en su equipo
jason bay frazier en of the night state
a dominar acá por todo ello kamala
harris es una historia de éxito en eeuu
la confirmación de que una mujer de raza
mixta de origen inmigrante y que apela a
los derechos civiles puede estar al
frente de la política del país perfilar
su carácter desde las más altas esferas
será su siguiente tarea los analistas
coinciden que para 2024 kamala harris
ante la avanzada edad de vaivén podría
ser la carta demócrata para intentar
seguir rompiendo barreras
a mí